>> THEY USE IT TO DESCRIBE
ANYTHING THEY DON'T LIKE.
>> Laura: SO WHO WILL WIN THE
WAR OF WORDS?
LET'S BRING IN FRANK LUND.
CAN THE DEMOCRATS SUCCESSFULLY
KIND OF WIGGLE OUT OF THIS GIVE
GIVEN, WHAT DID THEY DO HERE?
>> HALF OF ALL DEMOCRATS SAY
THEY WOULD VOTE FOR SOCIALISTS
AND THIS IS WORK THAT WE HAVE
DONE IN THE LAST EIGHT WEEKS.
WHAT YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW IS A
BATTLE, AND THAT'S A BATTLE
BETWEEN SOCIALISM AND ECONOMIC
FREEDOM.
THAT MEANS THAT GOVERNMENT
CONTROL, GOVERNMENT INCOME
INCONVENIENCE, BUT YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE MOVING FURTHER AND FURTHER
TO THE LEFT AND REPUBLICANS WILL
GET A MESSAGE TO ATTRACT THEM IF
THEY WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL.
>> Laura: IS AWARE THAT WE'VE
BEEN HEARING A LOT OF LATELY.
>> IT'S THE VALUES OF.
>> SENSE OF DIGNITY.
>> GOOD FOR YOU.
AND WE DID NOT TALK ABOUT THIS
BEFORE.
>> ABOUT TEN TIMES THEY
MENTIONED THAT.
>> CLEARLY SOMEONE IS ADVISING
MORE THAN ONE CANDIDATE AT THE
SAME TIME BUT WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO SAY IS RESPECT.
IF GOVERNMENT, THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T RESPECT YOU, THE ONLY
WAY THEY CAN GET AROUND THAT IS
BY RAISING HUMAN DIGNITY.
THAT WORK GOES BACK TO THE
1960s AND WAS FIRST USED FOR
EUROPEAN SOCIALISM.
I THINK IT WILL PLAY WELL.
>> Laura: WHEN THEY SAY
DIGNITY, HOWEVER, I THINK THEY
HEAR THE REPUBLICANS IN A MORE
CONSERVATIVE COME BACK AND SAY,
MEN.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE MOST
UNDIGNIFIED PEOPLE LET'S SAY IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT ELITES HAVE
SAID THE MOST HORRIFIC THINGS.
THEY CRITICIZED HIM FOR BEING
COURSE BUT, WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
IS, BEHEADED IMAGES OF TRUMP.
DISGUSTING IMAGES OF THEM
MELANIA.
TRUMP HASN'T GONE THERE YET.
HE HASN'T GONE TOWARD, DIGNITY.
HIS THIS DIGNIFIED?
OR INFANTICIDE, IS THAT
DIGNIFIED?
>> DIGNITY AS WELFARE, DIGNITY
AS FOOD STAMPS.
DIGNITY IS MORE GOVERNMENT
PROVIDING MORE SERVICES TO
PEOPLE.
>> FOR US, DIGNITY IS THE RIGHT
TO DETERMINE YOUR OWN DESTINY
WITHOUT GOVERNMENT INTERFERENCE.
>> .
>> HEALTH CARE IS A BASIC HUMAN
RIGHT.
RIGHT FOR FREE.
>> HEALTH CARE IS NOT JUST A
HUMAN RIGHT BUT AN AMERICAN
RIGHT.
>> GOOD FOR YOU.
>> Laura: I'M COMING FOR YOUR
JOB.
>> YOU WON'T NEED ME ANYMORE
BECAUSE THOSE VIDEOS ARE SO GOO
GOOD.
THE NUMBERS ARE INCREASING OVER
TIME.
MY CONCERN IS THE DEMOCRATS ARE
USING SOMETIMES LANGUAGE OF THE
RIGHT AS A WAY TO PUSH POLICIES
OF THE LEFT.
AND CONSERVATIVES HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT THAT.
HE WAS SOFTER, GENTLER, KINDER
WORDS TO PUSH THINGS THAT ARE
EITHER ABOUT GOVERNMENT CONTROL
AND THEY NEED TO HAVE AN ANSWER
TO THAT.
>> I THINK VICTOR DAVIS HANSON,
WHEN SOMETHING IS A HUMAN RIGHT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DEBATE IT
ANYMORE.
SO WHEN IT'S A -- YOU DON'T HAVE
TO GIVE IT TO THEM.
>> .
I'VE BEEN CRITICIZED THIS THOSE
ARE GOD-GIVEN RIGHTS AND THOSE
OTHER THINGS ARE NOT.
SO I CAME UP WITH A LANGUAGE
THAT YOU DESERVE AND I HAD
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT THING,
FRANK, DON'T DO THIS, IT'S NOT
RIGHT.
>> FINALLY HERE IS A MESSAGE
THAT I THINK TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS AND SOME OF HIS
SURROGATES WILL BE PUMPING OUT.
>> OUR GOAL IS PEACE AND
PROSPERITY, NOT WAR AND
DESTRUCTION.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT NEW
POSSIBILITIES FOR PEACE AND
PROSPERITY.
>> PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
>> Laura: INTERESTING, BECAUSE
THE REPUBLICANS ARE HAVEN'T
REALLY BEEN ON THE PISTE SIDE,
HAVE THEY?
>> NO, AND I SWEAR THEY'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING ME.
I HAD A MEETING AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT WAS THAT WORD
PEACE AND, WHERE WE NOT PERFORM
TO PROMOTING IT.
PEACE AND PROSPERITY A PRIORITY
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF THAT'S HIS THING AND HE'S
HEADED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
>> Laura: WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS THE OTHER DAY THAT
LIBERALS USE TO BELIEVE IN
PEACE.
THEY WERE THE ONE SAYING, MAKE
LOVE AND NOT WAR.
HOW COULD YOU KOWTOW TO THOSE
PEOPLE?
>> BUT LIBERALS ALSO BELIEVED IN
FREEDOM.
IF YOU GO BACK TO THE CROSBY
STILLS AND NASH SONGS, FREEDOM
WAS ALWAYS ON THE LEFT AND NOW
IT'S ON THE RIGHT.
>> Laura: AND CONTROL.
WE WILL BE UNPACKING THIS